hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
August 6th 2018 what's going on how are
you how you doing I am back I am back in
Los honglei's you know I think about Los
honglei's now everywhere else I go is
just as hot is here but it's not as nice
Oh everybody walking around sweating
their balls off you know you might as
well be out here in Hollywood with all
the real people the forward-thinking
progressive people how we we pushed the
needle we changed the needle we drive
the sled whatever the [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] we're always saying about ourselves
and you won't you won't find anybody out
here more funnier than me okay I'm
telling you that right now
you're gonna meet me and you can dig wow
that guy is so down to earth and I want
you to know it is all an act
okay you're not at my level sorry
anyways I just got back from I did
Rochester New York I believe that's the
first time I did a gig out there did it
with Dean Del Ray Dean Del Ray murdering
you know stealing the spotlight
everybody [ __ ] you know flipping out
about him you know he's so interesting
with his glasses in his tattoos and I
just come out right [ __ ] old
milquetoast Freddie right
nobody cares no I had a great time I had
a great time with that crowd what a
beautiful [ __ ] goddamn town but a
gorge why could I just say was a
beautiful town what a beautiful effing
GD town I have got to stop cursing
around my kid I have to I have to do
that I'm starting to do it with adults
where I just say like yeah the effort
the effort guys in a hole and then I
just go sorry I got a kid I need the
practice
[Laughter]
but is that any better because then my
kid's gonna be walk around like yeah
he's in a hole right it's people are
still gonna be like I don't know it
probably would still be adorable because
I have
I just came home and it was her nap time
but she I didn't so I was expecting her
to be asleep but it was five minutes
into her nap time but we have her on a
schedule and so I figured for sure she'd
be taking a nap and I came home and she
wasn't I was like tiptoeing in the house
and I heard these little feet come
running out Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada
that it is the best it's the best thing
ever one of the few things in life that
is not over height having a kid is the
the greatest thing ever
so anyways Rochester New York gorgeous
right so I get there and first thing I
see is a giant brick factory giant
factory smokestacks the whole thing
there's a little bit of steam coming out
of one of them but you know flying in
and I'm looking down and I you know I'm
doing all this I I have a private
pilot's license so I'm looking at the
clouds trying to guess what's going on
here is what you like you know patches
of clouds a little puff a little puff
their little put so what does that tell
me that tells me that there's there's
there's a lot of uneven air there that
we're gonna have little turbulence okay
because there's the the air is being
pushed up in certain areas it's not just
straight across but straight across and
it was even and they weren't like all
big and puffy you'd think okay that's
kind of some smooth [ __ ] air there
right I don't know if I'm right ground
school was a long time ago and I floud
here in LA and there's really no way
they should go along the coasts every
once in a while so I look down and I see
this factory and like I said it's it
looks like an old school thing or they
they brewing some beer they making some
steel what are they doing there
and I looked down and it was this giant
empty parking lot couldn't see any cars
and I was like I you know they'll just
turn that into lofts everything just
gets turned into a place to live you
know a place we made something I was a
place to go do something they'll just
take it and they'll turn into lofts and
it's just like we kept a lot of the
character of this place where we used to
make things so would you like to move
into this luxury apartment with your
Gucci bags
no you're only making fifty grand a
[ __ ] year or whatever that whatever
the [ __ ] it is people please don't be
that person
everybody because old freckles head I
got a bad I got kind of bad for you in
that it's like things are not adding up
out there everybody is walking around
with these Kardashian level outfits or a
lot of people are and the amount of
[ __ ] 20-somethings I see driving
around in BMWs it's like this everybody
have a [ __ ] Rich Dad out there you
driving around in a BMW okay with your
[ __ ] Gucci glasses and all of this
[ __ ] and then this is the thing nobody's
at work
this traffic 24 [ __ ] 7 I looked at a
census the population really isn't least
the legal population isn't really
growing in this country I don't think if
you are an illegal I don't think you're
driving around in a [ __ ] BMW
attracting all signs of attention to
yourself so unless everybody's a [ __ ]
uber driver but then where are they
driving all those people during the day
they're all late for work I don't know I
don't know what's going on
it this happens this happens like every
[ __ ] once every 10 years you know
first time I saw it was in the 80s
everybody was doing blow all the yuppies
everybody was [ __ ] walking around with
the Rolex and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then right there over all of a
sudden you're [ __ ] you had nothing
left in your nose like you've been
boxing for 20 years right skinny ties
are out sea cavalry Chi jeans are in
you're a [ __ ] cokehead
you [ __ ] up your whole life and they
repossessed your BMW then in the 90s
right it was a little rough time they're
a little rough time there and then you
know Bill Clinton came in according to
the Democrats he turned it all around he
saved it there was a zero [ __ ] you
know we had no debt he got us out of
debt you know of course you know he used
a couple of vaginas as a humidor but you
know everybody's gonna have their faults
what was he supposed to do balance the
budget play the saxophone and not [ __ ]
around and his wife I mean something's
got to give and I'm telling you that
right now is a sober [ __ ] person who
is not drank since June something has
got to give
you know maybe you go out you know maybe
you don't give in to the booze okay
maybe you don't bang an intern alright
but if you did maybe you lay off the ice
cream and you don't watch internet porn
and you're basically you're gonna paint
yourself into a corner and next thing
you know you're driving down the street
talking to yourself going am I really
gonna go out here and and and I guess do
a thrill kill so what I'm doing my gonna
kill a hitchhiker right now to just
somehow inject some sort of a rush into
my life right sorry umm anyways I'm
coming off the wagon tomorrow for one
day for one day only
me and Joe DeRosa ha ha ha ha ha ha ah
ha ha I'll tell you right now if our
livers could talk they would say let me
up throw in the towel get off of me I
don't know what they would say but it
would be they would give us a [ __ ] a
thrashing if they could speak anyways
that sounds like a [ __ ] book if your
organs could speak right and you just
stretch it out over like you know I'm
the organ see have like 10 you know one
days your liver next days your kidneys
you know and then one day it's you dick
what would your dick say to you you know
nothing smart you know you dicks never
gonna be like why did we [ __ ] that girl
you know you're [ __ ] your brain says
that you dick never says that you did
good why I mean she was there anyways
I tried pancreas is just would be like
the [ __ ] just the grizzled vet you
know Union tobor booth worker just sit
there with a cigarette dangling out of
his [ __ ] mouth doesn't give a [ __ ]
right it's getting close to its
retirement
I think the your kidneys would be the
most progressive and annoying he could
just drink some more water sorry anyways
so then after what is it after Rochester
I then drove down beautiful beautiful
drive from Rochester all the way down
into western Pennsylvania and then down
into Youngstown which I'd never gone to
and I would say Youngstown was like
three hours away from Ohio it's like an
hour and a half I thought Akron was way
down there - I thought they were way
down the [ __ ] east side down there
Pittsburgh and [ __ ] but they're not
there right there so I went got to go to
famous Youngstown I didn't get to see
[ __ ] I came in I saw that there was some
sort of Italian feast festival going on
in the streets which I would have loved
to partake in but I'm on my diet okay
I'm getting my revenge body everybody
know I'm sticking to my diet here I'm
actually doing really well with it until
this morning I couldn't find a place in
the airport that had oatmeal so I just I
got some bacon and eggs with hashbrowns
a toast but every other every other meal
I ate I hate the way I was supposed to
be eating so whatever that was my one
[ __ ] up and you don't have a cheat day
you have a cheat meal so that was a
cheat [ __ ] meal I got on the plane and
and the [ __ ] stewardess was like you
know I always have my headphones on
right and so she's got a wave in front
of me and I go yes and she goes what
would you like to drink I said water
with ice I go that's all I want that's
all in when I'm good alright and five
seconds later she's waving at me again
would you like to breakfast I was
getting mad at her like how the [ __ ] did
she know that that's what I meant for
the whole flight so I was like no no I'm
good I'm good I'll just have the [ __ ]
water you don't want anything
I didn't say that but I thought it and
she I could tell she was good at reading
people and she sensed it and she's like
this guy's a douche you know what's
funny was I was still wearing my suit
and tie that I had worn at the rough and
rowdy taping the night before because I
just didn't feel like packing the suit
and every once in a while if you have a
backpack and a little wheelie carry on
if you also have the garment bag
there'll be somebody like the Dudley
do-right you don't like the cop in the
middle of nowhere that has no excitement
so they gotta like [ __ ] you know see
how far away from the curb you parked so
they can give you a ticket someone will
say I'm sorry sir you have three items
you know and then she puts me okay in
the position to say oh excuse me ma'am
I'm flying first-class I'm allowed to
break the rules
okay I have I have I I go to your Sky
Lounge do you understand do you have any
idea what the she puts me in that
position or he but I never say that but
I definitely think it and that's what
makes me down-to-earth is I don't say
the things that I think so then the
world has no idea how [ __ ] arrogant I
am see that that's how that works
but you gotta have a little bit of
arrogance in life if you don't then no
one's ever gonna make a statue of you
that's how it works so anyway so we're
all waiting to line up and they're doing
the usual thing anybody active military
duty anybody with kids anybody with less
than four limbs you can board the plane
now and all this [ __ ] nobody budges I'm
like oh great here comes Group one and
all of a sudden this [ __ ] dude right
bald he's got the horseshoe you know
buzz down but he didn't shave the rest
of it walks by perfectly fine no
camouflage no [ __ ] limbs missing no
kids you know can see he's not deaf he
just walks by all of us he goes hey how
you doing hey what's up and he just
[ __ ] beeps his thing
and gets on the [ __ ] plane like what
are you gonna put on his little [ __ ]
outfit once he gets down the the jet way
there I don't know
anyways you would know I had a great
weekend uh so I get on the goddamn plane
and I'm like you know I didn't get a lot
of sleep because the rough and rowdy
event was [ __ ] unbelievable I am
gonna talk to you about that alright but
it's gonna be a great story here so I'm
sort of teasing that so you continue oh
wait you could fast-forward through all
this I I'm really into me TV and old
movies right now I just go through these
phases and I was watching this The
Postman Always Rings Twice which I
remember from the 80s and I thought it
was an original Brian to palm of him
film I didn't know he remade it but it
kind of seems like he took the name of
the movie and then he like switched it
up he did the Jimmy Page you know what I
mean like a Robert Plant just switched
the lyrics they wouldn't had a [ __ ]
problem because for the a lot of those
songs that Jimmy get in trouble for you
know he he changed the arrangement
enough that if Robert just switched up
the lyrics a little bit yeah I believe
it when he says that he that he wouldn't
got in trouble
our sued that many [ __ ] times so
anyways plowing ahead I'm watching this
thing and just some of the [ __ ] that
they say to women in these things this
guy was in love with this woman and they
were trying to plot killing her husband
and at some point they I don't know they
came up with the idea and they thought
it was a good idea and they could get
away with it and they were excited and
he just grabs both their arms and he
goes now kiss me before I sock you and
that was considered amusing back then
because guys didn't know how to express
love but there were guys beating women
were the guys beating women but when did
beating women become a fad like when did
that first happen I know grunge was in
the early 90s I'll have to look that up
and I'm gonna leave that open-ended to
cuz somebody's gonna post that and then
somebody's
gonna be like you know his bill perv
really that anyways and then I was
watching 77 Sunset Strip my favorite
[ __ ] show on TV and I'm into the
first season where they have like the
the matinee I'll look again Efrem
Zimbalist jr. ziz he's like not even in
episodes and when somebody was saying
was he was basically the Steve Urkel of
77 Sunset Strip they got him in there
and then he just kept getting more and
more and more lines and he just [ __ ]
took over and then they phased everybody
else out so anyways the the dreamboat
guy they're the lead of the show he's uh
he meets this woman she goes I'm
convinced my husband's trying to kill me
he's having an affair with this
secretary
you know if the brake lines were cut on
my car he almost accidentally hit me
with his boat and I think he tried to
poison me when he made me a drink
and what's funny is this woman is
gorgeous and this guy he's got to be 40
years older than her and which amazed me
that this guy was already gonna trade
her in you know because that's what
those guys do they just sort of collect
them like cars so not saying there's
anything wrong with that you know
there's nothing wrong with objectifying
a woman if it's that obvious you know
what I mean because she's what'swhat's
the material I guess gold-digging you
you know it's like I know you're here
for this stuff and you know I'm here so
you look good on my arm and I can you
know [ __ ] something that doesn't even
remotely look the way I do naked it's an
arrangement but what happens because
there's no love there somebody always
ends up pulling the plug first and then
it gets [ __ ] ugly so anyway she goes
this guy's trying to kill me she goes
I'm convinced he's having uh you know
he's having an affair with this his
secretary so he goes down over to the
office to investigate right and he comes
walking in and you know he's about ready
to meet a woman cuz the saxophone starts
playing which was what they always did
back there right they just play this
this beautiful asian woman comes walking
out and they just it's his secretary she
comes out and the saxophone does that
booboo deboard oh boo right
he's always hitting on him and [ __ ] and
this is his opening line der he goes yes
because they told me your boss imported
oriental art I have to agree that's what
he said the sad thing is is that same
[ __ ] is still set in a hooters every
[ __ ] night by a man of a certain age
and any grabbed her and said now kiss me
before I sock you you know it's funny
that's one of the first things I said to
neo when I first came home yeah it's
just some lines are too good you just
you just have to repeat them so anyways
let's get into rough and rowdy number
four from Youngstown unbelievable night
I don't think I'm telling you why I
can't believe I get paid to do that [ __ ]
it's just like it's so much [ __ ] fun
and I don't know it's just you just
hanging out watching people beat the
[ __ ] out of each other what's not to
like like I I just I don't know do you
just sit there watching the fights
neither the ones that are bad they
hilarious first of all the the the fight
card started off it had two brothers
like blood brothers fighting each other
and in their promo videos one was saying
that my mother never loved me you know
and I'm like oh Jesus it's this guy's
the victim of the family and then his
brother gets on and confirms it goes
yeah she [ __ ] hates him you know
always hated him right all he does is
sit around and play video games and I'm
in the National Guard and I'm out here
crushing it so the brother when his in
his you know little uh what do you call
Ric Flair sort of promo video he said
that the military's overrated they're a
bunch of they're soft
[ __ ] hilarious trashing his brother
and then they went out there and they
beat the [ __ ] out of each other now and
I had to root for the older brother
there's this unwritten rule I don't know
if it's something somebody told me or I
just I just I thought you can never let
your younger brother beat you up you
just cannot you cannot ever let that
happen you have to be in the mindset of
you know you're gonna have to murder me
and I know you don't want to go to jail
that's what you have to be mentally you
just can't have it cannot [ __ ] let
that happen
and I sat there and I watched it happen
on pay-per-view and I got to tell you as
an older brother it made me sick
great fight though a couple of
Youngstown firemen Jesus Christ one went
in there and just [ __ ] knock this guy
out to the it was the first time I saw a
guy really get knocked out where he went
to get back up again and went back down
again
first of all he when he first went down
he was doing that thing you know Bill
Gates try to do what's that thing that
the guy from the Carolina Panthers would
do after a touchdown it was a really
easy sort of move which is why white
people had ruined it so quickly you sort
of bring your arms out to the side
Dappen is that what they call it yeah he
looked like he was doing that the way
Bill Gates did well he didn't have his
elbow bent he just draped it across his
eyes like the Sun was beaming down there
he was laying there like that and and
then he rolled over and he went to get
up and he went [ __ ] back down again
and and it was yeah that happened and
then what else was some of the other
highlights Oh Pig first punk the cop
fighting the skateboard of the
skateboarder proved he was a punk
II didn't show up so at the last second
they got a bouncer so you got a cop and
you got a bouncer who's kidding who a
bouncer is just a cop that never went
pro right so it's a lot of overlap so
they [ __ ] get it in the ring and oh
my cop first of all I didn't realize he
had lost his job because he did a drive
along a ride-along whatever the [ __ ] you
call it and somehow the mayor got wind
of it you didn't [ __ ] like it so they
fired the guy and I got to tell you uh
barstool sports paid two years of the
guy's salary and anyways he went
in there in Jesus Christ and this was a
he fought a bouncing a granite the guy
didn't [ __ ] have any time to prepare
and and it looked like it holy [ __ ]
this guy was fast strong knew what the
[ __ ] he was doing a decent footwork
I mean you figure you know they're cops
they did teach him some of that MMA [ __ ]
will stand up a little how to choke a
guy out or whatever and he just he beat
the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] guy but I
tell you the bouncer could take a punch
man he [ __ ] he ate all of them until
the last one and then that was kind of
it and then the cut and the cop got off
off out of the ring and everyone's going
like reinstate reinstate like give him
his [ __ ] job back and then he
proceeded in the post interview I think
to ruin any chance of ever getting a job
as a cop anywhere they said to him they
go hey so are you upset you know did you
do that the mayor you know stepped in
and said to your police chief either
it's you or him I you upset with him now
what he should have said was like listen
there's a lot of variables involved I
have respect for the office of the mayor
and the mayor himself he was he did what
he felt was best and I'm not gonna argue
with that I'm just happy to have the
opportunity to come down here and give
the people of Youngstown some
entertainment that's what he should have
said but he didn't they got you upset
with the Mary's just like I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah I was [ __ ] mad I [ __ ] I
brought that [ __ ] anger in there
anything all right that's a wrap on the
criminal justice oh who knows
I will just say the tape is out there so
if anybody ever like were to do some
sort of I don't know internet search on
them but I think they kind of just
checked to see you know if you were
watching any porn
you know isn't that kind of where they
go I have no idea and then the end the
highlight the the headlining match gay
Pat versus the two-time convicted felon
homophobe
oh and I almost forgot to mention
Pat McAfee former punter of the kunti in
Indianapolis Colts
dude that guy absolutely crushed it as
he was the emcee for all the the major
day like four or five major fights and
he would go into the ring and do the
announcements and he was [ __ ]
hilarious hilarious this one guy went in
his name just will just say his name was
Edward Robinson the second and he was
like standing in the red corner in the
sloppy gray shorts and he will listen to
this whole [ __ ] he would like make
fun of you and then he says the guy's
name he could ESA's like he says Edward
Robinson the second the second there was
more than one I'm butchering his
delivery but he'd just the way he
[ __ ] ripped apart the fact that this
guy went by the second the fact that he
repeated the second again and then
tagged it with there was more than one
just so intelligently and so succinctly
[ __ ] basically says what everybody
thinks when they hear the second it's
like I know who gives a [ __ ] why you
acting like you're Henry the eighth you
know like you're some [ __ ] King
you're just some [ __ ] jackass nobody
gives a [ __ ] and they did that too with
the felon he is a two-time two-time
convicted he was [ __ ] unbelievable
un-fuckin'-believable
so anyways gay Pat goes in there and I'm
not gonna lie to you everybody was
nervous because it was you know it was
it was this guy's you know he's saying
on his [ __ ] homophobic [ __ ] I know he
was also playing a role he was also
helping you know sell the fight and
everything but like nobody wanted to see
that you know and I and I was really
happy that the whole crowd was on pat
side they would chant in his name gape
at gay Pat right and oh my god I almost
forgot [ __ ] raccoon boy this guy went
by raccoon boy he would wear
[ __ ] raccoon hat like Davy [ __ ]
Crockett and for whatever reason he came
down the aisle in a trash can one of
those recycle [ __ ] trash cans he was
in there peeking out like a [ __ ]
raccoon and they wheeled him down while
they did his intro and then he tried to
get his big body out of there with
boxing gloves on and it was some of the
best comedy I've seen in a while
he was very upset that they didn't let
him wear his his leather vest which I
thought in a very subtle way was him
giving support to gape at because it was
very Al Pacino cruising it didn't look
like a biker vest I guess when you're
shirtless you know he look like a fat
Freddie Mercury you know if like if
Freddie lived and continued to eat steak
bombs or started I should say he was
always in good shape right so anyways
and he went in there and he got he got
exterminated there was another one there
these two fat guys fight and one of the
fat guys was beating the share the other
guy who went by the Dale show and his
name was not Dale and he was getting
this [ __ ] kicked [ __ ] kicked out of him
and then the other dude had to stop
because he was so fat that the head gear
was choking him and what killed me was
it was like sort of looked like it was
underneath the bottom of his jaw but who
am I to say that it wasn't was probably
the combination of the strap-on in the
jaw and the eight pounds of blubber
around the guys neck and there was a lot
of [ __ ] wild-eyed people getting
pumped up and then wasting their energy
trying to turn fear into courage you
know like there was one guy he came out
and he's just swinging wildly and he got
a couple of punches in and then like his
headgear got messed her messed up so
they had to you know have a quick
stoppage and as they were fixing it he
was going like like flipping out and
like well this guy's [ __ ] crazy and
then he I don't think he landed another
punch for them for the rest of the fight
I think he let out all of that [ __ ]
energy and that was over so anyways and
this is all coming from a guy who would
get this [ __ ] kicked out of him by any
of these people ok so anyways gay Pat
comes in and he was just totally [ __ ]
calm went in there and then I saw the
convict
go on I'm like he's not that big he's
only five eight 180 so he's a little
stocky but he's not that tall and gape
at is six for a buck a knee so they
weighed the same so everybody knew that
the convict was gonna bulrush him and
everything and I got to tell you gay Pat
fought a filthy fight mayweather would
have been envious with the amount of
elbows this guy threw forearms to the
face he was leaning on him he used his
height he had a tremendous [ __ ]
strategy his corner was great they
trained him and he came out with the
victory and he got some good shots in
there too it was it was great it was one
of the it was such a [ __ ] relief that
he won because yeah I was getting
nervous that if he just came in and took
an overhand right and was knocked out
really bad and the crowd was actually
against him like that could have got
really ugly so uh kind of dancing
between the raindrops on that one but I
want to thank everybody at barstool
sports for letting me do that I
literally when I saw the arena and just
I just started to smile it like I can't
believe you know I go to a zillion
sporting events I've always want to be
in the broadcast booth I know this is
you know not at the professional level
but neither am i so the next one is
going to be in Kentucky outside this one
like the Thrilla in Manilla it's going
to be outside this is going to be at a
baseball stadium
I believe it's October fifth in Kentucky
unfortunately I don't think I'm gonna be
able to make that one because I believe
I have gigs I think I'm in Connecticut
in Boston that weekend but uh I'm
definitely going to rent it okay you get
it for fifteen bucks a few days right up
until the day of the fight day the fight
it's [ __ ] 1995 I'm telling you a
tremendous night of entertainment
anyways alright so now that I've done
that I'm gonna reach a little bit of
advertising here and then we're going to
talk Red Sox Yankees and New York fangs
hang in there okay don't think this is
don't think I'm gonna talk about this
the way ESPN did all right I am NOT in
that business
all right frame bridge everybody if
you've been listening to this show
you've heard me talk about frame bridge
they make it super easy
and affordable to frame your favorite
things from art prints and posters to
travel photos sitting on your phone
here's how it works I just did this for
all my fifth turn at 50 you know
pictures of me and my wife and Paris and
all that [ __ ] all that great trip that
we had I just sent them all the stuff
I'm supposed to be getting it this week
all right just go to frame bridge comm
and upload your photo or they'll send
you packaging to safety to safely mail
in your physical pieces come on preview
your item online in any frame style
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers well what's your favorite
color the expert team at frame bridge
will custom frame your item and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang instead of the
hundreds you pay at a framing store
their prices start at just $39 and all
shipping is free plus my listeners will
get 15% off their first order at frame
bridge comm when they use my code per
give your personal experience using
frame bridge I are how dare you ask me
to repeat myself frame bridge get
started today
frame your photos or send the perfect
gift for weddings birthdays and special
events go to frame bridge calm and use
promo code bar
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order just go to frame bridge calm
promo code per frame bridge calm promo
code bar all right Robin Hood all right
what is this stealing from the rich and
giving to the poor where was what was
the upside for him Robin
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
crypt cryptos all commissioned free they
strive to make Financial Services work
for everyone not just the wealthy
non-intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple and
intuitive clear design with data data
presented in an easy to digest way other
brokers charge up to $10 for every trade
but Robin
doesn't chart all that's why they don't
charge as much they no charge Commission
fees fees trade stocks and keep all you
and keep all your profits okay easy to
understand charts and mark a date data
place a trade in just four taps on your
smartphone so how do they make money
robin hood web platform also lets you
view stocks collecting collections 100
most popular selections like
entertainment social media and curated
categories like female CEOs what people
invest just because they have a female
CEO jesus christ this is just it's
[ __ ] nuts now and analysts ratings so
you can just do it you can start buying
stocks in a sexist way and analysts
ratings of buy hold slash sell for every
stock learn how to invest to build your
portfolio discover new stocks and
tracked favorite companies with
personalized news feed custom
notification for price movement so you
never missed the right moment to invest
robin hood is giving listeners a free
stock like apple 4-door sprint to help
build your portfolio well that's nice
sign up at bill burr dot robin hood
dot-com that's bill burr all caps dot
robin hood calm I like how they give you
this stock one free stock it's like the
drug dealer giving you a sample well you
like how that feels
we got some more over here alright zip
you know hiring used to be multiple job
site stacks of resumes a confusing
process but today hiring can be easy and
you only have to go to one place to get
it done zip burnup comm / / tip
recruiter sends your sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiting analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never mitts miss a great match again zip
is so effective that 80% of employees
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first day with revital results like that
I can't talk it's no wonder that zip
recruiter is the highest rated hiring
site in Amer rare car
and right now my listeners can try zip
dot-com for free and this exclusive web
address zip recruit comm / / that zip
recruiter dot-com / / zip recruit the
smartest way to hire that CIP are we see
are you iter I just imagine during that
whole read everybody's girlfriend a wife
going this isn't funny
laughing me undies biondi's be undies
[ __ ] your [ __ ] wife dudududu biondi's
be undies tell her to get a life stop
listen to me while this is this [ __ ]
I'll take out my dick and piss on your
tit and put on some up [ __ ] soft
underwear that rubs my balls better than
you since we've been married
how about alright you've heard me obsess
over me over me undies you've heard me
talk about how they are three times
softer than cotton and come with fun new
prints each month but I've got a big
scoop that I'm so excited to share with
you all the undies just gave their
membership a massive upgrade all those
dirty old hole ridden [ __ ] disgusting
underwear you've hung on to it's time to
throw them all out and give you a top
drawer the refresher it deserves each
month B again you keep your underwear
for a long time and you're a single guy
like you've worn those through
relationships you've worn those probably
the same pair of underwear when you
picked her up broke up with her and then
met the next [ __ ] chick each month
me undies
we'll release a new executive print that
only members can get well I gotta be
equal opportunity women you've probably
wore those panties since you went down
to the Virgin Island to get your [ __ ]
hair braided and bang some guy in the
island but didn't count it because it
was in a different country these could
be collaborations with artists brands or
other unique designs you're going to
definitely want to have members will
also pay less for everything on the me
undies website with special member
pricing that means if you want a second
pair of undies a Braille it or a lot or
lounge pants you'll play less than
anyone else the membership comes with no
strings attached unless you want some
kinky pair you know the women get like
the laces up the crack of their ass now
I don't think they make those over here
you can switch style and I say kinky how
old am I
skip the month or cancel at any time I
love these undies according to this copy
they are the softest underwear I've ever
put on according to them and they come
with fun prints that I can match with
socks or a bralette they come with 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
them you man just send them back for a
full refund the undies have a great
offer for my listeners for any listeners
for anybody for first times person
jurors purchasers purchasers when you
purchase any undies you get 50% off and
free shipping this is a no-brainer get
15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on alright
lastly but not leastly thank God man I
cannot [ __ ] my eyes are going I just
I'm old and I've never been able to read
out loud
alright stamps calm everybody the US
Postal Service is an important tool for
any business stamps comb is the easiest
way to access all the amazing services
of the post office stamps calm never
closes print postage for any letters or
packages at your convenience
24/7 print postage for any mail class
right from your own computer the exact
amount of postage every time never run
to pay or overpay stamps.com saves you
time and money which you can use to grow
your gdf and business you a hole see
that I'm practicing not cursing around
my kid buy and print official US
postage for any letter and he package
any class of mail using your own
computer they'll send you a digital
scale automatic that automatically
calculates exact postage stamps comm
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs no need to
lease an expensive postage meter and
there are no long term commitments I use
stamps comm to send out all my posters
that I'm selling on this tour I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure out how to do it
so can you and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
go to Stan's comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps.com enter
bur all right let's talk some baseball
bump-bump bump-bump bata Bob the Red Sox
sweep the Yankees four games [ __ ]
sweep we didn't have Chris sale data and
a Marin judge but the [ __ ] luck was
on our side I thought I thought if we
were lucky we were gonna split with them
you know and it was gonna be you know I
don't know what happened which is one of
those things we were hot they were not
and they should have won certainly the
last game the last two games they should
have won they blew leads and they
[ __ ] had a meltdown in the last one
so the Red Sox are now 9 and a half
games up so what does that mean to
people in sports radio and on ESPN and
all that [ __ ] you know what it means to
them the race is over you know why it's
over because we're up nine and a half
games there's 48 probably even more I
just I just counted the games in August
and in September what in the [ __ ] I'm
sitting that what are these people
talking about then it's like oh yeah
that's right they're in the job of
overhyping [ __ ] hype it up to the
[ __ ] goddamn moon and if it comes in
you look like a genius and if it doesn't
come in then you got to be like what
happened to the Red Sox what happened to
this guy what out what
the [ __ ] they start asking like acting
like like the teams that they hype said
they were gonna do what the [ __ ] they
said and I understand it now cuz they
are 24-hour Sports Network so what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do
during these 16 hours a day when there's
no [ __ ] games going on what are you
gonna do you just got it you got to go
big you got to say crazy [ __ ] so guys
like me lose their [ __ ] mind dude the
[ __ ] Red Sox were up by like 16 or 18
games in August in 1978 the Yankees came
to town that was the Boston Massacre we
had the one game playoff and then it was
over
the [ __ ] that the the Mets were like
9 million games out they came back in
1969 I don't have time to look all this
this [ __ ] happens almost like when
dude the Red Sox were up by like 12 13
games like like four or five years ago
2012 and we [ __ ] the bed didn't even
make the [ __ ] playoffs so we had
Valentine as a manager then the next
year we won the World Series so I don't
even know what they're talking about
here this is far from over we have six
games left alone with the Yankees we got
two series I believe with the Polli
bland Indians everybody's sleeping on
Terry Francona and the Cleveland Indians
I still think Terry's the best manager
in baseball I you know and what about
the Houston Astros they no slouches
either and how about the fact that
despite the fact the Yankees and nine
and a half games out there's still six
games up in the wild-card so according
to what I was watching that dude Mike
box-seat Mike from the old Mike and Mike
show now he's on a different show he was
saying the he according to him it's
essentially [ __ ] over despite the
fact that the Red Sox have blown leads
historically 18 12 game week why we we
[ __ ] this franchise alone is [ __ ] it
up twice in my life that I remember I
don't have time to look up the other
ones okay and then okay so now using
that logic I don't mean to just put it
on him because everybody was saying it
all right
using just that [ __ ] logic the
Yankees being up six games in the
wild-card they only need to be up six
games for another two weeks and then the
wild-card is over is that how the math
works that's another thing too all the
Yankees got to do is just keep playing
the way they've been playing all year
and they're gonna win the wild card okay
which means then we all go to the
playoffs we're all 0 and 0 so you know
what happened this weekend a whole bunch
of nothing because the greedy MLB wants
a wild card they want more people in the
playoffs so they make more [ __ ] money
cuz you know you can't make enough
[ __ ] money in defense of major league
baseball the Federal Reserve is a
private corporation that prints the
money for this country so they keep us
all running on the wheel even those guys
with their mistresses and their yachts
and their masquerade parties and all
that to the point they have to keep
adding rounds of baseball see like right
now as a Red Sox man I would be excited
that we swept the Yankees if there
wasn't a [ __ ] wild card that just
negates the whole thing so what is all
that that meant was maybe if we meet the
red the Yankees maybe 50/50 if we meet
the Yankees in the playoffs if we
continue to win the way we do the first
two games of the series will be played
at Fenway that's all that meant okay
everybody just stand down
and [ __ ] relax dude I got I got a bet
with my agent and Paul virzi I bet him
50 bucks each I've been doing it the
last two seasons we bet the the Red Sox
Yankees series you know whoever wins you
know the regular season series right and
then if we go to the playoffs I think
it'll bump up to a hundred bucks a game
each right keeps it fun it got me back
into baseball and I am [ __ ] loving
baseball now right those two guys they
they had to add their [ __ ] head in
the oven was hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious it's just like you
guys a Yankee we've been up 18 games and
you guys and you came back but the [ __ ]
is wrong with you Jesus Christ just
packing it in
maybe maybe actually question both of
them as human beings I really hope they
hear this you know Rosie right now you
can't rob a bank with that guy
the second anybody goes like if Ric
Flair walked by went wow you know he
would think the cops were coming and he
would just pack it in would that you
think he would think it was over now I
got to be thinking my agent you know
when a promoter pushes back a little bit
he's not getting me the best deal anyway
so there's plenty of time left I am
really looking forward to when the Red
Sox have a the Indians and then we also
play the Astros other two that I'm
paying attention to play the Astros on
September 7th 8th and 9th and I'm hoping
Justin Verlander is pitching because I
want to see how we do against their best
and then we get some you know yeah we
got to we got 1 Series in August I don't
have internet access here for some
[ __ ] reason but in September we got
the Indians on the 21st 22nd and 23rd
and then I believe we closed out
September I always think they don't they
play for the first three four games in
October but we have the Yankees 28 29 30
if not October 1st
maybe my cell phone will work here like
how funny is that with you have 48 games
left you're up 9 and a half games on
this one team that you're so you're
still gonna play six more times and
everybody's going yeah yeah man it's
[ __ ] over I'll tell you right now
that's why most people's dreams don't
come true you know not because of the
the patriotical [ __ ] structure
whatever the [ __ ] people are saying
nowadays it's cuz you quit all right and
I'm not saying that things aren't unfair
out there but like nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody everybody is too busy trying to
keep their [ __ ] afloat to have time to
give a [ __ ] about you and your [ __ ]
dream
all right so why don't you grow the [ __ ]
up I don't know I'm just trying to fill
time right here people I don't mean to
[ __ ] come down on you man what's next
October no game scheduled Wow look at
that no games in October I can't
remember the last time they finished the
regular season in September that's kind
of cool they play in the World Series in
like November now I guess they got to
get ready for all the playoffs all the
rounds of the playoffs playoffs anyways
alright let's read some so anyways it
was great to see them win all those
[ __ ] games it's nice to have that
kind of a lead but I am by no means
thinking that this this is over by any
stretch of the means I I will think that
it's over when we're up nine and a half
games with eight games left and the
Yankees are out of the wild-card -
that's when it's over other than that
it's it's it's game on there
all right frame bridge everybody if
you've been listening to this show oh
wait what the [ __ ] am i doing I'm
reading the goddamn advertising all
right podcast comment hey Bill on your
latest episode on Jesus Christ I really
feel like we need to [ __ ] here you're
you said you don't appeal to women but
just want to let you know you have a
yeah okay that creep me up all right
just for the record I'm 50 years old
that was from a 23 year old I swear if I
[ __ ] said across the table from a 23
year old I give her a rattle you will
woogie-boogie why we hated why we hate
other redheads Jesus Christ hey what's
up Billy no glutes I was listening to an
old podcast when you were talking about
the Paper Planes music video and that a
group of redheads made you feel weird
yeah was weird to see cuz you never you
never see us
you never see just a giant group of
redheads you know we're like the spice
in the stew you know what I mean we're
not we're not the beef in the stew right
I can say that I totally agree with you
on that part but I would actually go a
little bit further with it of course you
would say and say that I hate or despise
other redheads oh this is a self-hating
redhead I didn't say I was a self-hating
redhead
oh Jesus here's my reason though they
make me look bad
simple I'm a normal guy kind of tall
try to hit the gym often enough so I
have what you once called a standing
six-pack but most of the [ __ ]
redheads are a [ __ ] disgrace just out
of shape dorky unathletic unfunny losers
with no charm don't get me wrong there
are exceptions but not many anyway go
[ __ ] yourself and bring your balding
redheaded ass to Iceland you [ __ ] I
think with any group that gets picked on
you're hypersensitive in a negative way
to the way the people around you're
behaving because I know it's I've seen
the big pasty freckled shapeless arms
that for some reason they're wearing
like a tank top I I definitely agree
with you I do feel not not necessarily
with women I do feel with guys is a
redheaded male there's a certain level
of shape you have to stay in because
you're already gonna get picked on I am
I do understand some of that but I am
NOT a I'm not self-hating I don't hate
the way I look I actually think I'm a
good-looking guy I do make fun of myself
but like I don't know I don't get it
like I'd never been anything else so I
don't know what the [ __ ] you know that
would be like but uh I do feel bad for
redheaded kids now because of you know
that South Park episode like the level
of [ __ ] that that part like that that
probably started you know I can't I
can't can I play and I can't blame them
I'm too big of a fan I would
say maybe whatever that kick a gingered
a came around like I'm so glad I can't
tell if I'm glad that that wasn't around
when I was a kid or I'm kind of jealous
because at least you knew what day to
fake sick on you know as a redhead like
whereas when I was coming up they kind
of seemed like that was more of a week
rather than a day bought out whatever
you don't what doesn't kill you makes me
stronger all right Tom Cruise helicopter
okay hey there Billy bald the wise Billy
bald the wise I always feel like this I
should be figuring out what the [ __ ]
that means
bald wise the wise that's another
English word kind of Billy bald the wise
is that like a character I don't know
anyways just wanted to hear your
thoughts on the new Mission Impossible
film I have to see it I haven't seen it
yet I'm seeing three movies this week
I'm seeing the mr. Rogers movie I'm
seeing eighth grade and I'm seeing
Mission Impossible alright so I'm seeing
something from my childhood I'm seeing
how Millennials deal with being in the
8th grade and then I'm just watching a
big summer blockbuster so I feel like I
got a nice [ __ ] you know Smorgasburg
of what the [ __ ] going on out there
alright just want to hear your thoughts
in a new Mission Impossible and how Tom
Cruise is notorious for doing his own
stunts do people understand what the
word notorious means that that's like
that's basically known usually for a bad
thing
I'd say he's famous for doing his own
stunts I feel like a lot of people don't
know what infamous and notorious means
anyways I read he learned how to fly a
helicopter in about three months for the
film as a pilot yourself that seems like
a short amount of time for someone to do
the action sequence and stunt work that
was displayed check out the link below
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself well I think
this there there there is a lot at least
look they're trying to sell a movie so
whatever he did they're gonna they're
gonna shrink it down but I don't care
how long or how
or the amount of time he did what he did
took an unbelievable amount of [ __ ]
balls and I was talking to some director
he goes I can tell you without a doubt
they definitely shot that [ __ ] on the
last day
meaning if he killed himself that think
they could all be easily put a stuntman
in there and they would still have a
movie I don't know I I've just only seen
the movie clip and but there is no
[ __ ] way ever in my piloting career
would I ever do anything like that ever
that's all I can tell you no [ __ ] way
I like to live you know that's my [ __ ]
and I don't have problem with stuntmen I
really don't you know I don't want to
see them act and they don't want to see
me jump in front of a [ __ ] moving car
and I stay out of there late I look how
I'm acting like I'm at Tom Cruise's
level I just like that [ __ ] where you
jump from one building to another and
they kept it in the film and he like
broke his foot or something like that
yeah that's like like Jackie Chan does
[ __ ] like that and then Tom takes it to
the next level where he's like does he
as far as I think he essentially just
knows the helicopter over and just was
flying straight down at the earth while
spinning I believe added that to it
which I really believe is hard enough to
do in a [ __ ] airplane
forget about on a helicopter like I
don't understand I don't know how that
works but uh you know hats off to that
guy that guy is and he can also fly like
a like a [ __ ] jet like a g5 like just
get in the thing and fly to England like
I believe he's that level of a pilot I
would tell you though I would definitely
rather fly with John Travolta cuz it
seems like you know he dresses up like
the captain and he just you know
straight and level it just sort of flies
where I feel like Tom Cruise Bing oh
[ __ ] look at that and it would just do a
[ __ ] barrel roll just to scare you so
he can laugh at you I'm Evan have a long
time ago telling a story on [ __ ]
Letterman where
they they were upfront and they thought
it was funny and they depressurized the
cabin and they made the guy in the back
pass out they didn't like 100% but they
somehow made the the oxygen I don't know
the mixture of it I don't if there was
too much oxygen so he [ __ ] overloaded
on it and got lightheaded and passed out
I don't know but I'll remember he was
crying laughing when he said it and I
was like yeah he's [ __ ] guys nuts but
I'm definitely gonna see the movie and I
am a huge Tom Cruise fan I and I think
you know he's one of those guys I didn't
realize how big a fan I was until one
day they listed all this movies and I
realized I saw like 80% of them that's
kind of like when you go to somebody
drags you to a concert like yeah I know
where they are I mean I'm a radio fan of
them and then you get there and you're
like oh [ __ ] they sing this song too
oh my god you know you come home you
download and all their music that's what
Tom Cruise is like well I can't wait to
see the movie it's perfect it's got Tom
Cruise it's got helicopters and they
shot a lot of it in Paris I mean I'm in
it's over anyways lady asking for advice
yeah hey Billy no buns
I'm loving this you motivate me I'm
going to the gym right after this and
I'm doing some school I'm a 23 year old
woman oh by the way I cannot I I got one
of those little [ __ ] you know you
know those little foam rollers I already
had one of those but I've been using
that religiously and then I got one of
those little balls that you can just
roll out your [ __ ] legs your glutes
your back the whole [ __ ] thing when
you're on the road if you're an old
person like me it is a game changer game
changer anyways I'm a 23 year old woman
from London and I love your podcast oh
thank you I'm crushing it with the 23
year old ladies this week you always say
you want to hear from more of us ladies
I do because it gets to once one sided
so here I am I would love your advice on
my current situation my parents were
quite strict when I was growing up so I
never I have never been on a date before
yeah I would say that goes
a little beyond quite strict I would say
suffocating I still live at home I'm
studying for my masters they are less
strict now as my brother is now married
and they are now more comfortable with
me dating well what the [ __ ] is their
problem hey dude that's that's like sad
you should you know let's say go out and
[ __ ] you know get gangbanged here but
I you know go out and you know go on a
date experience finding love losing it
and [ __ ] that weird thing when you
finally erased a number other than phone
I mean I can't either your phone I can't
believe you missed all that anyways I'm
studying part-time and I am working for
the rest of the time how do I go about
meeting new people the people I work
with are all in their mid-40s and don't
really socialize outside of work any
advice would be appreciated alright
number one don't [ __ ] any of those forty
year olds okay you work with them and
they're old don't do it okay God knows
where the [ __ ] those old dicks have been
stay away from them alright you like a
[ __ ] one of those you know you know
was those nerds by the Star Wars action
figures and it's a big thing if the box
has never been opened your box has never
been opened alright it's worth a lot of
money there and also you're asking me
how to meet people when I've been out of
the dating scene for like fifteen years
fifty years old and at no point in my
life was I still living at home studying
for my masters while having a job I love
that you felt enough about me that you
thought at some point in my life I
attained that level of success and was
that pressed for time how do I go about
meeting new people don't you guys just
like go on apps dating apps you know
what I'm actually good I'm gonna phone a
friend on this one the rest of the
podcast listeners guys how do you do it
ladies I should ask the ladies how in
this day and age could someone with a
vagina
twenty-three-year-old vagina that has
not had the seal broken yet
how can they go out into the dating
world avoid the dirty dicks and actually
have a nice entry into the dating world
a positive experience that's gonna make
her not be jaded and think that maybe
her parents were right for [ __ ] you
know keeping her chained to a radiator
for the first quarter century of her
life how should she go about doing I I
think feel like dating apps is a lot of
guys on there just trying to [ __ ] you
know and then they Dizzy's no no that's
that app that's that Apple people just
trying to hook up this app is the more
serious app well what's to prevent
someone to go on there and just act like
they're looking for a relationship when
they just want to bang you so the first
thing I would say if you have the time
is you need some sort of activity that
you're involved in that involves you
socializing with you know men and women
basically I don't know what it is you
know go into bars getting hammered and
[ __ ] that's usually not gonna you're not
gonna meet a nice guy there for the most
part I would say I don't know
join us softball volleyball it was I
mean I'm old [ __ ] start riding a dirt
bike
maybe you meet some guys out there in
the trail the dusty dicks I mean I don't
I don't know I don't know how to help
you here I'm sorry I I'm yeah and get it
I got a phone a friend here you guys got
to help me out here help this lady okay
put on on in in the subject put uh what
are you would 23 fresh box
alright fresh box 23 let's call it that
alright and you said it's email me your
advice okay and then we could [ __ ]
figure it out we can help this lady up
because you know
I have empathy for you that you're late
to the game I own up late to the game I
showed up at about [ __ ] halftime down
40 points alright dilemma would you
rather get punched in the head by Mike
Tyson in his prime or get kicked squared
in the nuts by Bruce Lee Oh easy Bruce
Lee without a dump not a dud I would go
to a sperm bank kept my sperm frozen
before I had that happen and you know
then I would still have my brain intact
to intelligently be able to tell the
woman that I ended up falling in love
with why I allowed the greatest Asian of
all time to kick me square in the nuts
ooh
I mean Mike Tyson I'd still have my
balls but I might be drooling on them
afterwards as I said that day I was a
disgusting image I didn't mean to say
that all right for the for the Tyson
choice oh I'm sorry your hands are tied
behind your back okay now I have details
your hands are tied behind your back
Tyson can wind up and is told to cause
maximum damage to your head with one
punch it's going to be his famous
overhand right yeah now [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that you know there's nothing to is this
way better footage on Mike Tyson than
there is on Bruce Lee for the Bruce Lee
choice you are spread eagle and cannot
defend yourself I assumed you can only
wear a European man thong to give you a
semblance of dignity I appreciate that
Bruce Lee is told to cause max maximum
damage to your manhood with one kick he
will get a running start do you choose
Mike Tyson or Bruce Lee I still gotta go
with Bruce Lee you know what I mean what
is my quality of life gonna be if Mike
Tyson gives me permanent [ __ ] brain
damage but my junk is still intact all
right it
Bruce Lee obliterates my dick and balls
but I've already frozen my [ __ ] sperm
I could still have kids I don't know I
let my wife [ __ ] other guys I guess I
don't know I don't know what to do at
that point but you know I could still
have my brain but then my brain would be
all day long and a loop going you don't
have any junk you don't have any junk
you know I mean junk yeah but you know
what if I still had my brain I could be
smart enough to figure out how to kill
myself
all right so I would go with the Bruce
Lee you know it would be funnier than
watching me get kicked in the balls
spread-eagle wearing a European man
thong isn't you know the only thing
funnier than that would be the yell that
I let out as Bruce Lee was running at me
I think it would sound a little like
this just be like it would and then
watching my inner thighs flexing as I
tried hopelessly to try to close my legs
oh that would be the worst - if your
legs were tied spread-eagle I mean
immediately get kicked in the balls you
go into the fetal position I would not
be able to do that you know which I
would think it would make it your body
stay and even more of panic mode because
you go in a fetal position you know it
kind of covers up your junk unless you
have old man balls and they squirt out
the back right
at which point somebody walks by and
accidentally kicks them you know like
when you [ __ ] think you clear the
door and you actually stub your toe all
right that was disgusting okay that's
the podcast man I hope you guys enjoyed
it thank you to everybody that came out
Rochester thank you to all the guys I
almost said rough and rowdy everybody a
barstool sports rough and rowdy I had
such a great time and thank you to all
the competitors that showed up and
entertained everybody I had such a great
time if there's a way for me to get to
the one in Kentucky I'm
to be there if I can't I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be watching it either in
Connecticut or in Boston Massachusetts
with a bunch of my friends that's it old
freckles is in town this week and I
think my next date I have is in Las
Vegas on August 18th I believe that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll check in on
you on Thursday